I what I saw at Gleason Gleason was what
I wanted to be I I just thought Jackie
Gleason was just amazing you know and I
I said I want to be like that guy you
know because he was incredible and it
was people in her eyes he was a stand-up
you know no Gleason did Stan oh yeah
really one night 2-ton toni collette
that was giving him shit and the boxer
and Gleason tackled him and come out
yeah it was incredible you know cuz I
met odd Connie you know Jackie Gleason
was obsessed with UFOs did you know that
nah but I got kind of dig it - man
that's a story this guy told it to me
some guy who's a rock band dude he told
me the story and I don't know if it's
true but the story was that Gleason was
friends with Nixon Nixon said you want
to see some shit yeah Nixon took him to
151 was I don't think it was area 51 I
think was hangar 18 which is a there's
an Air Force Base and I think it was
outside of Columbus Ohio and they they
supposedly had some fucking crashed UFO
there and Gleason built a replica of it
or had a replica of it built in his
fucking backyard in New York Wow I went
to the homestead Air Force Base outside
of Miami it says the actual version
where are you getting this from just
google it I mean it's a rumored story so
I don't know yeah well I got it from a
guy in a band might might be bullshit
but he gave me some book on UFOs he was
telling me about this and but the Jackie
Gleason apparently was obsessed with
UFOs well I I believe this there's got
to be something out there yeah I don't
were it I mean that's it no every I I
did money you were so shows and I've
been around the world and it was every
time I thought I was in off the coast of
Turkey someplace and the commander the
base took me for dinner after it's and I
got him drunk I got a pretty truck I was
so but stomach I'm pretty duck and I
said hey man you guys let me ask you
about area 51 he goes got stoned so
because
this conversation happened and he left
and I got to take a cab to find my way
back to a new place that that no one
knows about right so then we're uh I
mean I'm at the dunes that's how long
ago that was and I'm with these guys or
in the Air Force and I got they said man
we really like show with fancy husband I
got him drunk I say man what about every
a51 and they said mr. Claude good night
they walked away so now me and Mike a
golfing with these blue angels and he
goes you're gonna ask Michael no the
second year we golf with him again I got
iPhones tell me about every 51 yeah well
he goes I was flying a plane and I had
malfunctioned I'll land there and they
came out and they pretty much blindfold
to me took me into a building and they
fixed my jet within 35 minutes and then
put me back to him I say you were never
here
and I went oh my god so I don't know
what's out there
yeah but that was here's the thing that
was an area where they were testing all
sorts of military equipment they were
testing different new like that's where
the b-2 stealth bomber right they were
testing that there and and the spy plane
yeah they were testing a lot of shit
yeah yeah so there was a lot of
top-secret stuff there right didn't
necessarily happy aliens I understand
that and I'm hoping to find out i but
I'd love to go there man oh man but you
can't even try if you drive up there Joe
by the time you get your camera out
there they're on you yeah tell you what
you get out of here we'll lock you up
you know it's it's not good so they
don't even go there anymore they've
moved to a new area they've they've
actually because it's so heavily
scrutinized because of Google Earth and
all sorts of different ways you can see
things they've actually moved to another
area but I've read I read everything I
could find about that too and I think I
I think I read the book area 51 couple
two years ago and basically at the end
of the book it was like Hitler had these
you know his guys experimenting with the
Jews and cut and put their arms on
different ways and had a had an aircraft
that was looked like a spaceship and it
crashed and his people came out with him
but they're aliens and now that was in
the book you know so they can't shut the
shit out of it I know they'd Hitler did
experiment with some sort of disc type
round what the deal was but the most
interesting stories the story of Robert
Lazar Bob Lazar who was a guy who worked
at area 51 and he got fired because his
wife was cheating on him and they were
recording all of his phone calls and
taping all his conversations and they
found out that his wife was cheating on
him they thought that he was gonna be
emotionally unstable and so they didn't
tell him why they just released him so
then he brings friends to watch these
what he said was were alien crafts that
they were experimenting with and they
were flying these things around that had
some super advanced propulsion system
that they were asking him to help back
engineer and he brought friends do that
and he got arrested for doing that and
when he did that then he started talking
about it so he's been discredited by a
bunch of people but I don't know who's
telling the truth he says that they they
wiped his college record so the new one
but people said they went to school with
them and he definitely did work for the
government but under what capacity who
knows but his story's fascinating and
you know I want it to be true oh yeah
you hear it you want it to be Joe they
used to fly the team of people that
worked at area 51 from Burbank yeah
every day climate they work and then
flying back it's like they didn't stay
over well there was that one Airport
outside of Vegas it was right outside
like there where the Riviera was yeah
you can actually look out and see the
airport and they would fly them the
people from there but it's like mark
Jets yeah I want it to be sure of course
yeah you want it to be true